here's our function quick note they've
written it as log with no base I don't
like writing when I have a choice I
don't like writing log with no base
because my brain sort of fizzles out and
gets confused so I'll either write base
E or I will write Ln I think in most
cases I'll write Ln cuz I'm lazy
but in this case and you'll see why in a
second I've actually written base a
because I want to highlight the fact
that there's a base there and I'm gonna
do something with it in a second
question a says write down the domain
now just before we get like fully like
stuck into tangled up in the question I
want you to note that what we are doing
now draws together a lot of threads from
the rest of the course right it's why in
your HSC exam for 20% of it will be
prelim content stuff from last year
because in maths you cannot escape the
things that you learn two or three or
ten years ago it's all one big coherent
whole okay so to find the domain of this
maybe the first thing you do is I don't
remember how to find domain okay with
domain for certain functions it's really
easy for instance if I gave you this we
instinctively know the shape of that
because we've been dealing with it for a
couple of years now so you're like oh I
know you can have the left part you can
have the right part it's just the bit
right in the middle that's no good right
so I know the domain of this logs though
less common okay maybe it helps you to
remember what a normal log function
looks like it looks like this so that
picture is hopefully in your brain so
you can see that this implies a domain
right namely X is greater than greater
than what's what's this boundary yeah
it's just greater than zero okay now we
have something a little more complicated
than that
okay so helping you like work out what's
going on X is greater than zero because
what does a log mean people in my class
know I really like this metaphor but
maybe others haven't heard of it before
I like to think of logs as trying to
work out how long does something take to
grow so see this thing here right
this statement is parallel to this
statement yeah so imagine I have a
machine that doubles things every minute
okay every minute you put something in
the machine it's obviously a very large
machine it doubles in size so
if you were there for five minutes right
if you left that object in there then
what you would end with is something 32
times the size of what you started with
yeah so what does this mean it's asking
the same question from the other
perspective if I put you in the doubling
machine and I want you to end up this
big 32 times bigger right I want you to
be giant moon or whatever it's called
it's gonna take me five minutes okay
five minutes and what does this mean
okay well this is saying how long does a
we know if that is two point seven one
etc how long does that take to grow into
whatever these numbers are going to mean
that's variable okay but the kid I'm
trying to get out here which makes sense
of this is that if you are growing you
can go forwards in time you'll get
bigger you can go backwards in time
you'll get smaller but at no point will
this thing ever be negative in size does
that make sense
you make it bigger and bigger it can go
huge you can make it small and small
it'll get tiny tiny tiny tiny tiny tiny
but it will never get negative it's like
oh I possess negative volume okay
doesn't make sense so that's why X is
greater than zero this thing here has to
be greater than zero does that make
sense
so my question then becomes okay well
when does one plus x squared when is
that greater than zero hmm this is for
domain I should've said okay well I know
what this thing looks like like I just
draw a quick and dirty graph over here x
squared is just the regular parabola
what difference is the one plus make it
shifts it vertically up one unit right
so this is one plus x squared so it's
not a trick question when is that thing
that parabola when is it above zero and
the answer is it is always above zero
there's no part of this parabola that
that floats beneath the axis so
therefore when is this true and the
answer is any real values of X it can
exist anywhere you can put any values of
X in there and it's happy that's a bit
weird because they're used to logs
having a domain restriction but this guy
does not okay so there is part a done
Part B I'm just going to artfully skip
because the results that you require are
there are we
wipe them though so I've got my first
derivative in which we use our we use
the log differentiation rule that we've
just developed then when you go to the
second derivative you're differentiating
this so you no longer have a log to deal
with you unfortunately cannot avoid
quotient rule here so that's why you end
up with this result
so I'll just jot that down like so it's
squared isn't it happy times okay so
you've got those I don't think you all
had too much trouble with them part CNN
says hence show that okay so it says
hence what does that mean again I must
use the previous part sometimes multiple
parts okay show that it's got one
stationary point and determine its
nature which part of the working that I
have right now is to do with stationary
points it's the it's the first
derivative this guy yeah so I'm gonna
use that to find where the stationary
point is and then being that I've
already got this the second area I might
as well use that to determine the nature
does that make sense okay so how do I do
this well how do you find a stationary
point what do you do with this thing
very good so stationary points occur
remember if you're stationary point
sorry if your first derivative is zero
you're guaranteed of a stationary point
points inflection there where you like
maybe maybe not stationary points
definitely occur when your first
derivative is zero okay now that's the
first root --iv you guys can probably
see it's quite easy to deal with have
you found the stationary point where is
it it's it's at the origin right so dot
dot dot you're gonna have to go through
some working there to show what the
value is to show what the Y value is you
get a stationary point at 0 0
what kind of stationary point is it it's
a local minimum how can you tell
yeah when you put 0 into here when you
put x equals 0 I should say you get two
times one on what are you going to
denominator what's it's become it's just
one so you just get 2 that means it's
concave up that's a minimum okay so I'm
just because
not the focus of what we're working on
right now I'm just going to write that
and I think you guys were okay with that
all right so a picture is gradually
forming in your mind you've got all real
values of X this guy can go anywhere
you've got a stationary point which is a
local minimum down here at the origin
what's next what do they request after
this